6h et la cisr c'est parti c'est toi
georges lacoeuilhe vraiment on s'en sort
il a habillé comme tu étais quand est ce
que tu nous paraît pas mais qu'est ce
que tu ne prépares enquête parlementaire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il avait perdu les valides c'est parti
d'un garçon c'était l'événement monsieur
on recevait mon acteur préféré après
lorànt deutsch christian clavier alors
qu'ils sont calés c'est le seul qui
pourrait vous piquer votre tarbes à
cyril pourquoi ce site parce que sa
cible préférée justement c'est vous
j'ai passé une caméra isolé sur question
vous connaissez le cfc bien sûr là vous
allez découvrir le cic je connais
regardez moi ça c'est l'habitude la
personne préfère au monde se dit alors
c'est très content de recevoir question
clin d'oeil à droite avait l'impression
que c'était réciproque parce qu'il n'a
fait que des compliments à commencer par
votre pantalon et ça c'est pas terrible
histoire c'est pas donné mais pour toi
question est là c'est réussi
si si ça fait plaisir mais enfin même en
charge le port de moscou qui revient
après est ce que tu veux bien que je
m'occupe de ton look un jour une journée
qui me semblent sera dans dix ans est ce
que tu penses que sherlock holmes ça
vraiment existé oui donc ça s'est il dit
la vérité
je vous fais un petit truc a pu enfin
plus ou moins plus ou moins de cinq ans
mais c'est ça le problème c'est que il
ya au bout d'un moment
manipulation sa gelée remarqué dans
l'émission ayant prédit on n'entend rien
de ce que vous êtes très puissant la
télé alors il vous a pas lâchés avec ce
mot puissant c'est vraiment le gars qui
vous veut y est très très puissant il
croyait vraiment que j'ai les moyens de
payer quelqu'un oui en plus c'est très
très puissant
je veux arrêter monsieur calvi dans le
paf il est très puissant qu'il ya une
ambiance ici c'est quand même bizarre
qui passe de temps en temps on rigole on
rigole mais aussi à gages très content
mais ça peut ça peut virer vinaigre ok
oui je fasse le rôle de pascal elbé
aussi ne serait relativement amusé voilà
enfin il fallait abandonner très
puissant ici peut pas 19 août n'est pas
possible ou si on a la patience et le
qualifie cependant pas du califat donc
en fait tu étais totalement le roi là
dedans
sur bien des genres astrum aux pulsions
de jeunes et record d'audience hier pour
ppp 1,7 minute espérant des parties 1
million de l'employeur par terre l'étude
fait cent mille personnes dès le début
des moussons merci à tous et très de
l'été leader largement sur les jeunes ni
encore donc bravo merci à vous et sur
les personnes plus âgées aussi nous
regarde tout le monde nous a regardés
merci revenus c'est grâce à vous oui
c'est grâce à vous non pas grâce à bien
sûr c'est que tous les brasseurs grâce à
toi mon bébé c'est gentil merci en a pas
alors privé de bellis effet d'un guépard
les les hommes les plus célèbres du
monde comme neymar ou maxime gainey
avant l'émission ramzy vous allez
confier un secret syrie ouais et qu on
peut vous faire contente il avait
construit alors qu'il a confié à franck
gastambide à michaël youn et il joue dur
il n'a y pas confier à moi et je dis
maintenant voilà il avait confié être de
trois copains mois et ils ont une
maladie
mes amis ils ne peuvent pas s'empêcher
de me répéter les choses vraiment et ils
disent 'voilà excuse nous rami on a une
maladie à chaque fois même tu nous dis
ne pas répéter bon on répète
voilà vous avez la même maladie de lyme
murray pc vous et moi j'ai la maladie de
mes copains et ben voilà tout ce mal à
dire on répète tout est bien sûr secret
en plus c'est un million cinq cent mille
personnes mais c'est pas grave donc
qu'il y ait donc le fantasme de ramzi
rêve de faire un nouveau duo kelly et
ramzy ah ouais il est fou amoureux doit
pas parler d'autre chose qui compte
alors malheureusement pour hamid non il
n'y a rien qui intéresse le cyril
hanouna que les histoires d'amour alors
il balaie tout fait jusqu'à ce qu'il
obtienne ce qu'il veut dans l'indre
donne un ticket elle te dis voilà tu
peux partir avec qui tu veux pendant un
an avait lui donner ce qu'il est si sa
femme donne politique
[Rires]
alors amis avoue enfin parce que fils
etc sinon il va y passer toute
l'émission avec est ce que oui ou non
c'est kelly est ce que c'est qu'ils
disent oui c'est qu'il a regardée comme
qu'il y ait un vide apprend qu'elle est
le fantôme de racks y regarder elle une
réponse positive aller parce que ça vous
intéresse
nomi je suis mariée tout va bien visite
secrète avec ça alors amusé j'ai envie
d'entendre la réponse positive de kenny
là oublient qu'une réponse positive
d'une meuf n'a rien à voir la réponse
positive d'un mec regardez là dès 13 ans
les jeux de ramener deux grands frères
pique nique tu l es tu en fais partie ah
merde c'est pas sérieux
[Musique]
regardez aussi la tête depuis son caddie
clinique mais j'ai encore de la promo à
faire avec lui
justement justement parce que je pense
qu'on était tous focalisés sur la tête
de détresse de ramsey est dangereux et
qu'on revoie la séquence
ah ouais ça peut vous concentrer sur
question qui voit son ami prendre un
râteau en direct quand même en même
temps c'est un mélange de compassion et
de bas c'est normal frérot j'adore
regarder deux gros frais actuels ouais
et tu en fais partie ah merde s'est
passé en afrique
[Musique]
[Rires]
vous voulez vous voir
est focalisée sur christian création
chez vous vraiment les chéris focalise
écoute sur l'île c'est exceptionnel
regarder cultuel et tu en fais partie ah
merde t'es pas certain que ça nous fait
surtout un diktat yade il ya des
nouvelles données actions tel sommet
exceptionnel est radié aussi d'ailleurs
et c'est pas fini qui semble que quand
on est chroniqueur et qu'on apprend
qu'on reçoit christian clavier on sait
qu'on va beaucoup parler et donc on va
être payé à rien [ __ ]
oui comme d'habitude en fait y en a qui
ont essayé y aurait des problèmes
rappelez vous cette magnifique et qui
sont qualité tellement chaud qu'il a
clashé tous les gens en plateau même une
personne qui était tranquillement devant
sa télé regardez-moi ça face à la
légende christian clavier les
chroniqueurs ont essayé d'exister
c'était une grande réussite this is an
au nom mal m'a appelé avant les [ __ ]
ticket sur toi ce que tu voulais parti
c'est le dit oui ou par témoin prend
tout de suite une semaine de tactique et
surtout na waie à bonbons et pourquoi
cette intervention
[Rires]
ton père a refait le nez de 2,2 d'une
actrice
oui oui c'est vrai qu'elle est bonne on
ne peut pas dire qu'ils aient dit
laquelle on non ça me déçoit tout
puisque d'habitude une élégance et
finesse
laquelle
j'ai vécu là je prenne pas
d'éclaboussures continent non mais quand
vous savez vous qu'une feuille d une ag
à bon merci très beau témoignage est
donc même ramzy son collègue de boulot
de boulot ces fèves année parquet sans
que la bbc aujourd'hui jean n'aura dit
ce matin de lui parler et que tu lui
parles tu connais tu le tour ainsi rien
on sera lequel des deux rames giroud
question chez moi éloquence et par
benjamin castaldi qui se fait clasher
dans tpm pc son père s'est fait tatouer
les peuples était le porteur de
questions que hilary rien devant thébaux
connecte en paix on le faisait tous
porté une journée sans être payés en
êtes payé la question qu'a dit encore
non message accepterait pas moi qui
tourne sans être payés oui ou non il
faut qu'ils payent pour donner avec moi
la vie n'a tort
merci se récuser
son grade exceptionnel brabandère de
mandat